hey guys my name is Jess McHale today
it's the 18th of MAS and Joe change into
games but use the sub sony's online TV
service playstation view has revealed
its pricing and you should probably
prepare yourself because it's a little
steep view is currently available only
in New York Chicago and Philadelphia but
it'll make its way to other markets
before too long Sony network
entertainment vice president eric lam
pearl has called view quote a complete
TV offering it's live TV it's catch-up
TV it's a DVR in the cloud so it gives
our users everything that we think they
want it may be all those things but it's
also kind of expensive starting at 50
bucks a month for the basic 50 channel
package and getting up to seventy
dollars a month for the elite option
there has another dozen or so channels
the question at the moment is if
customers really want 50 channels they
may or may not be interested in or of
consumers these days are more interested
in a la carte offerings like HBO Go Hulu
Plus and Netflix PlayStation have said
they think there is a growing taste for
bundled channels according to their
research but then some people have
pointed out why would you not instead go
for a traditional cable option that
offers 200 channels the advantage to
view is said to be its accessibility
across three different devices although
only one ps4 and it's basically cable TV
without actually needing to get the
cable installed you also won't need
PlayStation Plus to access the service
in stories that will make you want to
move to Denmark there's a promotion plan
where you can trade your actual blood
for a copy of blood-borne the
excellently cool move was coordinated by
re partnership with Playstation and
Danish blood sent take your blood the
promotion is intended to raise awareness
for the lack of blood donors in the
country if you find yourself in Denmark
you can attend the event held on March
23 at the IT University of Copenhagen
and receive either a free copy of
blood-borne or a different PlayStation
game
participants will also be entered in X
sweepstakes with a chance to grab a
specially designed blood-borne ps4
finally if you're a bad person who
parroted your copy of Windows Microsoft
are still happy to give you that free
upgrade to Windows 10 for some reason
one can only assume Microsoft are
desperate to battle the Apple hoards and
keep users on Windows exact Terry
Myerson told the verge anyone with a
qualified device can upgrade to Windows
10 including those with pirated copies
of windows we believe customers over
time will realize the value of properly
licensing windows and we will make it
easy for them to move to legitimate
copies it kind of sounds like a guilt
trip but it could be a smooth moves from
Microsoft for his next major operating
system is set to land sometime this
summer let me know down in the comments
how you liked to consume your TV we've
fought service and why you can have the
game spot to see a richer three 4k image
and valve proves where they got such a
bad grade for customer service those are
all the good things that I wanted to
tell you about today but do check back
with me tomorrow for a bunch more new
thing